what's up reject nation if you didn't
catch part one of our reaction to the
mandalorian season two finale
there's a link in the description box
and pin comment anywho
this is part two enjoy
look at his wheel he's holding the dark
saver
why don't you kill him now and take it
no
exactly oh no it's yours now
what is the darkest dog you want it man
it belongs to beat him in combat no
she can't take it she would need to
defeat you
in combat sabine wren gave it to her
though
i yield it's yours
[Laughter]
perfect without that blade
she's a pretender to the throne
oh you [ __ ] come on just take it
i'm not gonna tell anyone we're being
boarded
how many life forms none
[Music]
oh damn
[Music]
i oh should
really look sound feel heavy
oh i love the crafting of this does you
have phase one to show
how hard they are yeah and then give you
a false movement
and then be like oh friends oh come on
oh you [ __ ] come on you like threw him
right
onto one yeah right onto a blast gonna
place you right here
right here where the gun is of this
mcguffin
i'm gonna get you out of here
otherwise it's gonna be a really
disappointing finale we wouldn't even
have time to get to a jedi at this point
they're here they have like this cgi
stop-motion thing about them too you
know
it's interesting the way they did
i mean but they have to get wiped out
right
otherwise the first order
[Laughter]
couldn't you just like dark saber
through all their heads as they run in
i wonder if they designed it where the
lightsabers couldn't cut through
an x-wing incoming craft identify
yourself
or no is it him
are they doing it
i'm just going to be like waiting very
patiently right now
oh oh it's got me it's got me luke
that's who he was talking to i can't
believe they're doing this
they brought him in
wow is it actually yeah
oh my god hello look the last giant jedi
didn't give you the action you wanted so
we're giving it to you
all the music
no
oh jesus
oh my god thank heavens
oh oh no oh yeah oh
about to have an anxiety attack
this is a great way to have his presence
felt
but to answer the question a lightsaber
can defeat
[Music]
yes moving all graceful like
oh bring him to me
oh ah nice
oh nice oh yes
oh
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] no uncommando
oh it's the reflection
they just full-on did it
he is strong with the force but he will
not be safe until he masters his
abilities
i'll see you again oh i promise
oh no
oh you're afraid
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it's okay let it let it out
wow
ah
[Laughter]
for context
oh dude
oh no i can't believe this
[Applause]
[ __ ]
holy crap got two in this season that's
off my god
okay just feel it just feel it it's all
there
the whole time we're drawn beforehand
about it sure where my glasses are
contact oh we're american
i wonder if he's gonna be like a time
jump for the next one after he's been
like a little bit more trained yeah
we'll jump to when he's like 150.
what a powerful episode but what becomes
of the dark saber
well that's where we find out the next
time i guess maybe that maybe we'll
shift focus for a little while to the
situation to the actual
mandalorian and stuff yeah damn we
didn't even
we didn't get a result
that episode took so much i i know so
much
holy crap what a journey that was
non-stop
it just the second it started it's like
it did a bunch of things i was hoping
and then it and then it and then it
you know kicked it up into overdrive
like it led with a bunch of stuff i'd
been hoping to see and then
yeah all right
oh tattering
jabba's palace
oh crap oh we're setting up season three
there's your boy
what wow bring him back for a second
damn shove his body right yeah
no way oh my goodness
keep man oh my
holy crap
oh it looks like a comic book yeah
i was gonna say this is a new spin-off
series that we didn't yeah december
oh that'll be season three it'll be
mandalorian season 3am
the rumors i'm sure it won't be only
boba fett i bet it'll focus on that but
then also do
like denjar and eventually and all that
i mean he's gonna need somebody else's
mission to get tied up in
yeah yeah so i think that's how it'll go
damn that was surprising yeah
bring fortuna back for a moment
[Laughter]
hey man i mean if you're gonna do it
like if you're gonna
maybe maybe that'll start exploring the
you know how he got out of the sarlacc
pit maybe some flashbacks yeah
this will get out of the sarlacc pit all
right let's talk about him has it
a whole lot dank ferrick
wow okay so much to talk about here
i mean yeah all right so we're oh it's
like sorry
i'm literally i literally just got a
message
i know someone who's directing an
episode of season three and he just
messaged me
so what did you think i'm
literally reviewing it right now
holy [ __ ]
and he won't tell me anything about it
obviously he's not allowed toonie and i
prefer he doesn't yeah
i'm doing it
literally being recorded right now
reviewing it the reaction will be up
tomorrow
you just get his thoughts and then read
them off see what you do
for season three man no he hasn't told
me anything so
yeah man yeah no spoilers no scoops
oh boy okay
that's why his timing could not be more
impeccable it's like
he's hacked into your disney plus he's
like i can see when you're watching
i want to probe him for questions but
i'm like but you'd ruin the reaction for
me now you're gonna have to watch out i
can't even talk in passing about
this was my probably my favorite episode
of the entire series
this was so good it completes other than
you know knowing what happens with grogu
it completes a lot of the story wraps up
a lot of it obviously
you know moff gideon is gonna be taken
away by car dune has to be
put in jail i'm sure he's gonna be in
there plotting his evil plan
and then uh man if only i could ask this
guy some questions i could really just
get some answers here
the most comprehensive i need to put my
photo i need to stop talking to him
i need to not look at my phone it's like
gideon's got to be taken away you wrap
up this arc
they gave you everything you wanted you
think about the entire series we've seen
so far but this whole season as
a whole building up with the jedi uh
that's something that he's connected
with someone and he has to go away and
train with someone
getting the best gar steel uh spear in
that exact episode when he learned the
information that grogan needs to go with
the jedi and then how it just
and then also getting bokeh tan in here
it all just comes full circle in this
moment
this one episode of them having to work
together bokeh tim wanting to go after
him i don't know maybe you guys can
clarify some things for me
because i just i rewatched the episode
last night sabine ran handed off
the darksaber to bo katan she didn't
fight boko tanford she helped
sabine wren destroy the machine that she
built yadda yadda yadda but samin was
also like i feel like you're the
rightful ruler to lead these people you
have the leadership
skills so here take the dart and then
she she accepts it and then holds it
reunites the people
so she forgot about it yeah
traditionally in the rules to get the
dark saber you have to you usually have
to go through combat you have to win it
you have to earn it
yeah i guess that might just be it there
was nothing there that
maybe in their dynamics so far that
hasn't demonstrated
for dinjarin even though he could care
less about it
yeah it's like because there was a
pre-existing bond between her and sabine
wren of sorts you know yeah and they
work together and all these things so
it's like maybe because of that personal
element it's not just like some random
guy being like yeah i don't want this
you can have it yeah
you know like there's a better
connective quality there that still
it doesn't dismantle the pride and hint
towards the lie that gideon's exactly
like
you'll know that you didn't actually
earn it you know yeah
yeah that's true that's true but damn
gin carlos esposito's performance in
this episode oh it's great so amazing
like he's barely in this season and then
you get him here and there's so much
great
like to me this this is emmy nominated
worthy performance right here
i thought it was amazing he's so good to
the point where you can have him
outnumbered in a room
full of armed people and the moment
where you're like oh he's spinning the
wheels
he's about to talk his way out of this
or he's about to have something up his
sleeve
that's gonna make this all for naught or
something like he's so good at bringing
that like
really assured really confident very
like eerily still and steady energy
yeah and it's like he is one of those
actors now who's sort of been
typecast as these type of heavy roles
but it's all props to him because
he's able to bring such presence
distinctly
to each one and like here it was so
rewarding to watch him go up against
ninja and to watch
him actually have to really fight him
but then overpower him get him on the
ground
you know and then take him to bogatan so
rewarding i mean but yeah
even when he's captured and he's like
cuffed and bleeding from the mouth yeah
something about him where you're like
why is he still so menacing why is he
still so scary
right now even though he's caught yeah
and then that one moment where he
actually looks scared
is like so impactful because of that
when you see it when luke skywalker
shows up yeah and he's like oh [ __ ]
yeah i even i didn't expect this yeah
right the fight with gideon and dinger
was really cool that was a great battle
they had i wish it was longer though
that was the one thing about it it was i
wish it was just a little bit longer
i don't know of it just because it was
so exciting and i was so pulled into it
that it felt
short well there's but there's so much
build up with the fact that he's ha
you you introduce him with the darksaber
at the end of season one you know a
couple of times he's taunting with it
you're like okay what kind of lethal
warrior is this guy going to be and then
the fight built a little
a little short-lived it's not even
really that big of a deal to me because
i'm still like i'm still so cool
so awesome and rewarding to get him
using the best scar sphere versus him
with the dark side you're like that is
so neat
i love it i can't really complain well
they've also
drawn up a lot of other tension
throughout the episode especially with
the dark troopers and stuff like that
like that fight scene where
dinger is just getting his face now
painful
like i thought i was afraid that was
like getting crushed by a machine
literally and for a second i was like oh
god they're not going to like actually
crush his head or something like it
hunting yeah and so i feel like there is
an element of the structure of this
episode that's interesting because
to a degree their plan goes pretty well
according to plan
minus the fact that you know gideon
hides away with grogu and all that stuff
and the attempt at you know
creating some kind of alliance or
momentary
satisfaction of mutual interests or
whatever but yeah it seems like in the
first part of the episode
there's a lot of tension as the
operation
unfolds but it pretty much is a success
and then they bring you
some more surprises right after that
yeah they did such a good job
with the dark troopers i thought more of
terminator one than terminator 2
yeah you know like specifically when
sarah connor's running away
from the t800 and it's melted down
because there's something about the way
it moved
that had this eerie stop-motion effect
like didn't feel
totally cgi it just made it feel that
much more unsettling whenever it was
doing stuff and it just
feels so heavy and the color is so it's
it's weird like i love the way they
depicted them because
they're so dark like the metal you're
looking at them you're like these are
reflective surfaces
but they have such dark color that it
just
sucks all the light in and makes them
look that much scarier because then yeah
it's just the glowing red eyes and the
outlines and the idea of their shape
i mean this whole episode was just great
because that the beginning of this
when they're uh they're they're plotting
they have they're making it seem like oh
slave one's after us and they're on the
ship it just made me
think of like classic star wars movies
these rogue characters all going on a
rescue mission
having to infiltrate this galactic ship
get out there start fighting some
stormtroopers but then they had their
own
spin on it and like the the gun action
was so
cool everything with uh cause her name
costco reeves of namaste
new character reeves the sasha banks
character you guys see her do some
wrestling moves when she's fighting boba
fett when they're all working together
on the ship to take out all their storm
troopers and stuff
and i do think they're very selective
about when the storm troopers are good
at their job and when they're not good
at their job because
the closer you are
they're good from afar but once you're
right up in their grill they're there
but more so in this show than the movies
because
the episode when boba fett was you know
before he got the armor we were showing
how badass the robert rodriguez directed
one the tragedy is what it's called that
episode i thought they were doing a
really good job but even in the one with
bill burr
when uh the stormtroopers show up and
they start shooting the pirates i'm like
oh damn
good job [ __ ] and then here you're like
oh come on the complaint is so
minor to me at this point it's one of
those star wars things too
where it's like they've become
self-conscious of it so many times now
that i think it helps to take that edge
off almost i mean beyond that it's
yes and the fact that the choreography
and
what was on display because they didn't
all move the same like bokeh tan and
reeves they kind of moved somewhere
because of their you know the regimen
they're from the mandalorians they are
with
cara dune and fennec shan you even get a
display of differences in them i thought
like
fenik and kara were so awesome here the
ending moments with mando
and um baby yoda having i mean they
still call them
their non-real names denjar and croco
having to say goodbye to each other and
him taking off the helmet showing like
no this you are
the most important thing in the world to
me more than this religion and stuff
like he had to look at him he had to see
him it was so heartbreaking
i think a lot of us predicted that's
probably what would happen i think we
even said it ourselves like it
set it up for that that he would have to
go away and train with the jedi and it
seemed likely that it would be
cal or luke makes more sense especially
because they're going more within the
the movies and such that it would be
luke skywalker
sidestep here luke skywalker showed up
yeah like there's an x thing i'm like
who the hell is it but then once i
realized
it's a solo x-wing it's gotta be luke
skywalker
the guy that you've run into all this
season with your beard who's just always
like hey
guys what are you doing here that's what
i thought it was multiple ships i would
have been like oh the republic's showing
up when it was one i was like oh my god
this is it look in that x-wing
there was something about the fighting
style of how they captured him which i
thought was really good at building
by cutting back and forth between how
much he's effing those guys up
and then cutting to the reaction moments
from everyone on the ship the way
dinjaran and grow goo were reacting
specifically like
denjard and grogu were very different in
the way they were responding versus
everyone else who was like this guy's a
threat don't trust this person grogu is
obviously holding reaching out to him
and uh you know even touching the camera
really drawn to luke but when he's like
messing them all up the choreography is
so awesome and it kind of reminded me of
a hybrid
of the rogue one darth vader scene and
actually that star wars fan film the
scene 38 reimagined
where darth vader versus obi wan it it
had
that type of visual aesthetic more than
actually the rogue one
version to me yeah and i thought that
was great to see that is
especially after you know we never saw
luke move this way in any of the live
action stuff
you know he gets brought back in uh last
jedi and he doesn't really do much in
terms of the fighting to get
this paid off here was so grand it was
uh it was awesome i will say though
damn cgi i love the look of his face
especially the eyes
when he first showed up i was like oh
cool looks good
yeah but then when he started talking
you get the dead eyes
yeah i was wondering if they would do a
full-on yeah we're just doing a hero
shot
we're just going to have a scene with
luke and yeah i mean i'm glad that they
i'm
really glad that they introduced him the
way they did just leading with this
presence and the body language and
really
showing from both the screen and then
cutting in just really
building the aura around him and then
yeah like it was a funny moment because
i was like oh damn like they really
actually did it yeah
and it is like really exciting it's a i
think it's a really good
lore thing it makes a lot of sense on
the timeline and whatnot i wish this
technology was just a little further
along
but i feel like you know it's one of
those moments where i can easily see
past whatever little nitpicks into the
context you know that's what i mean the
context was so absorbing yeah that i was
like
i literally had a quick thought like
ignored just enjoy it
yeah it didn't feel like one of those
things where it's like oh we're going to
do a dh moment
bring a character in that we didn't need
to it's not just that we're going
uh it's star wars just forget about a
flaw it's a technology flaw but
we're talking about context and story
and all those things the emotional
undertones that's really small compared
to
i mean some people might have want to
recast but i don't think we're gonna get
season three
of watching grogu and luke train with
one another so
just be the reverse yeah if you're gonna
do one scene with luke skywalker maybe
another one in season three it's totally
cool to just
keep it yeah he wouldn't even know mark
hamill was there
yeah yeah especially seeing the credit
like okay mark hamill actually did
maybe like he did the voice obviously i
was like that's just too good a voice if
that's fake
i'm sure they did some audio pitch stuff
to make him sound younger still they had
to
sound a little modulated yeah yeah
because at first i was like is this
like dialogue they just took from the
previous movie yeah i mean this is the
journey we've been on
in a lot of ways this completes the the
story of dinjara and
and grogu of for now for now i think
though that we will eventually get back
to dinjara and i don't think he can do
this show without dinjarn and grogu i
feel like we'll
get some focus on boba fett but i think
you also got to go to dinjar and
eventually we're there you end up
uh having them reunite because this is
great it's not unlike
the last year like they established so
much with luke skywalker's story
in the last jedi and we're very close to
the time when rey supposed to be born
and kylo and you know ben solo the
krogers that were there
unless he was like one of the jedi who
was killed at the temple then that just
sucks
so i think you gotta in terms of
thinking about this
canon of storylines it has to eventually
get there but then they also do say that
he took his blood moff gideon he can
restore
order i like the way they did moff
gideon's lines when he was talking with
danjarin he really talked about bo katan
and fenix
all the people on the ship that how
murderous savages they are like he
really views them like they're the bad
guys and that
they want that he can bring order back
to the galaxy with what grogu has
i imagine is that that must go feed
right into the whole thing with the
clones and stoke and palpatine and all
that yeah it seems like they're really
tying it all in and now we're gonna get
all these other shows too that'll tie it
all in and flesh it out or even more i
mean
this is already so tied to clone wars
and rebels yeah i'm like coming out of
the other live action shows they're
gonna
tie it in even more now yeah it's like a
giant map that just keeps
having regions
oh that's how that place connects to
that place yeah yeah so it's like
it's weird because it's like you're
watching these different timelines not
in a non-linear fashion but i like that
i think it's cool i think it's a
different way to experience it well yeah
and it's a good way to keep your
history like it's a it's a world that
has
its own history and chronology now like
it's been expanded over so much and it's
a good way i think to
keep that collective bibliography alive
without having to constantly go
remember that thing remember that thing
yeah like we will do that but i feel
like yeah just the more you
build the living percolating quality of
this world yeah the more that you can
kind of
refer without feeling lord you know i
think pedro pascal did a great job on
his performance
i thought everyone did a wonderful job i
mean it would make sense to go into
season three too with the
honestly if it was just a boba fett show
i wouldn't want that i i don't think i
would not
i personally when i i don't mind
focusing on boba fett yeah am i focusing
on whatever
this storyline is and whatever we
uncover i would not like it if we just
can't all the din jar and because we got
all this dark saber stuff
to figure out too and and what's going
on with mandalore maybe we'll get some
like
fennec and and boba and then we'll go to
boca tan
and uh dinjarin and see what it's all
about we're restoring mandalore and then
we'll finally see
mandalore in live action yeah i would
definitely want to continue with
denjaran in some way shape
of course because it only seems right
and then
uh yeah i mean we're done yeah but guys
this was um
this was incredible i thought they
knocked it out of the park
absolutely i just i'm so catherst then
tuna got killed right away at the end
bring it back
don't worry they can bring it back this
is so hilarious to me
good punchline there need to be more of
those member berries
remember this guy jimmy olsen all right
guys so what do you think thank you so
much for being here
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button if you enjoyed this
video
thank you to everyone to join our
patreon page this is the way leave your
predictions down below for season three